[موسيقى]
حسنًا، يبدو الأمر غير واقعي بالنسبة لي، لكن
في نفس الوقت يجب أن أواصل
القيام بما يجب علي تحسينه، كما
تعلمون العمل عليه أيضًا، فأنت تبلغ من العمر
19 عامًا فقط وأنت صغير جدًا على ما أتخيل
بعض اللاعبين الذين تلعب
معهم كانوا يكبرون نوعًا ما من لاعبي الأيدولز الخاص بك، كيف يبدو الأمر
الآن أنك تتنافس
معهم، إنه لأمر مدهش سأقول
إنه من المدهش أنني ألعب مع أفضل
اللاعبين في العام الماضي وهو أمر رائع جدًا
اللعب معهم جنبًا إلى جنب
لأنني أعتقد أنه كان لدي الكثير
لأتعلمه منهم لأنني أملك
وجهًا جديدًا مثل
اللقب النموذجي جينو الذي يأمل في البناء
على سمعة تايلاند في
كرة القدم للسيدات،
فنحن جميعًا نحاول إلهام
الجيل القادم لـ  ننمو في المختبرات ومن ثم نكون
في جولة LPGA ونود أن
نرى البعض مثل لاعبي الجولف الكبار هنا في
LPGA لذا فأنت تعلم أننا نحاول
تخصيص بعض الوقت لإلهامهم كل
يوم
[موسيقى]
مثل جميع لاعبي الجولف جينو  لقد كانت دقيقة
بشأن إعداد حقيبتها وقد
قامت ببعض الإضافات الجديدة لعام 2023،
هذه هي الأندية ونريد إلقاء
نظرة عليها نعم بالتأكيد ما الجديد
في حقيبتي، إنه سائقي وأحذيتي الثلاثة،
لذلك أعتقد أنها مميزة جدًا بالنسبة لي
لهذا العام لأنني أحب
لونه وأعجبني ما تم
أداؤه بالنسبة لي هذا العام، انظر إلى
ذلك نعم هذا مضحك جدًا نعم
ولكن الرأس أكثر جمالًا، أعتقد أنه تم
اللعب مع الشمس  اللون،
لذا أتطلع أخيرًا إلى عام 2023،
هل حصلت على فوز كبير في نظرك
نعم أريد ذلك، أحاول أن أبذل
قصارى جهدي وأتمنى أن
يحدث ذلك قريبًا